طبعا نقش التعاون العسكري اليوم كان هناك
لقاء بين وزيرين الدفاع
لا نعلن عاده ما هو نوع التعاون الذي
سنقوم به بيننا وبين روسيا لان هذا موضوع
عسكري يبقى دائما له نوع من السريه هذا
شيء طبيعي اما بالنسبه للقواعد العسكريه
فهذا يعود
لرؤيه مشتركه فيها جانب سياسي وفيها جانب
عسكري من الناحيه العسكريه لم يناقش هذا
الموضوع امامنا ناحيه السياسيه فنظر الى
القواعد العسكريه لا يجب ان ترتبط بموضوع
مكافحه الارهاب مكافحه الارهاب يا امر
قائم حاليا ولكنه سيكون مؤقت ولا يمكن
للوجود العسكري الروسي في اي دوله ان يبنى
على شيء مؤقت نحن نتحدث عن توازن دولي
وجود روسيا في سوريا له اهميه مرتبطه
بالتوبه بتوازن القوى في العالم كدوله
موجوده على البحر المتوسط لا يمكن للدول
العظمى اليوم
ان تحمي نفسها او ان تلعب دورها من داخل
حدودها لابد ان تلعب الدور من خارج الحدود
من خلال حلفاء موجودين في العالم ومن خلال
قواعد فنحن نفترض بان اذا كان هناك
رغبه روسيه في توسيع القواعد او زياده
عددها وهذا موضوع فني او لوجستي اذا كان
هناك رغبه فهي في ضمن من ضمن هذا الاطار
ونعتقد بان توسيع الوجود الروسي في سوريا
هو شيء جيد يخدم هذه الفكره كما سيكون اذا
كان هذا التوسع في دول اخرى ربما في مناطق
اخرى سيخدم نفس الفكره فنعم نقول بان هذا
الشيء قد يكون ضروري في المستقبل